Well, I appreciate your interest in wanting to be a Fort Worth police officer.
What makes you think you're qualified?
If you could see on my resume, I have ruled over the Imperial Force for sometime.
It had great success in ruling the galaxies.
What is this about a Death Star blowing up under your command?
I was cleared of that.
Not my fault.
You can see per my resume, I'm quite proficient at using the Force.
Well, we refer to it as use of force...
...and I don't think that's quite the same thing you think it is.
Also, we require our recruits to pass a physical assessment test...
...and quite honestly, you sound like you have a deep breathing issue.
Do you think that's gonna be a problem?
You don't have to worry about my breathing because I can disarm a suspect...
...without having to chase him.
How can you do that?
Give me that.
Okay, I think we're done here.
You want to hire me.
What?
I am the recruit you are looking for.
Okay.
Thanks for your time, we'll let you know.
Do you, by chance, validate?
Please leave.